I think that it's becoming more
acceptable to express a view like I'm
sick of pride month
I don't think that necessarily
translates we'll see but I don't think
it necessarily translates into a bump
for example repealing gay marriage but I
do think that two years ago it was I was
very fringy for saying that I was
extreme for saying that
two or three years ago in a way that I
don't feel extreme saying it now so I
think yes it has become more acceptable
in a moderate to conservative space to
say yeah I'm tired of pride month I
don't need to see this I don't need to
see men in chaps I don't need to see any
of this in the Public Square